Daniel asks numbers of monthly active
users aside do you think Instagram is
actually a larger social network than
Twitter Daniel I think that uh its rim
and Twitter are tremendously different I
think Twitter is kind of the townhall
the cocktail party of our society when
things happen in the world you know
that's where we're going you know
unfortunate hostage situation in Sydney
I'm not running to insta to see the
pictures I'm running to Twitter for the
conversation on the flip side I do not
believe there's a social network in the
world that exists right now that has
more of the end attention of the
consumer than Instagram meaning we're
looking at those pictures pretty
carefully in this world by comparison
you know it's you know this episode's
gonna tie nice together because nicely
because I know the other questions and I
know my push for insta I think it's
about attention on the gram and I think
that's where it's really winning I think
people are really consuming content and
paying attention one of the reasons that
Twitter is evolving is you know I used
to be able to send a tweet six years ago
and even though with substantially less
of an audience of reach I had more
action because the attention was more
serious now the firehose has gotten so
intense so those are the variables you
know from a net-net game of attention I
think it's pretty close but Instagram is
clearly going in the right direction
they just look back differently that's
all oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe